foreign
Seattle what's up Jessica
hi Dr John how are you good how are you
I am doing fantastic it just feels a
little surreal I'm really happy to talk
to you I don't ever get to talk to
Seattle people it's a home place that's
the birthplace of uh Pearl Jam and
Allison Chains and all the good sound
guard it is we're just up here being
depressed so we can't get on the phone
to call you because the weather's so bad
I know we don't have any good music
coming out of Nashville because we're
all too busy being outside and enjoying
the weather and all that kind of all
that vitamin D see we're so we're so
Overjoyed we don't know what to do with
ourselves that's right that's right you
guys gotta work on that we will we will
all right so what's up
uh I want to ask you I don't hear a lot
of borderline personality questions from
when I've listened to you before I've
got a 70 year old mom with borderline
personality disorder
I am her only child
she's divorced
and I'm kind of watching her taking a
steep decline since she and my dad got
divorced
and I just need some advice from you on
what you think I should do or if I
should be doing any more that I'm
already doing who diagnosed her is that
a true diagnosis was that just off the
internet
so I grew up believing that she was
manic depressive
and then last year she told me that the
counselor or the therapist that she's
been meeting reviewed her notes from
when she was hospitalized maybe like 30
years ago
and there was a BPD diagnosis in there
so not helpful okay
so this is
looked into it completely checks out
yeah
so one I don't like Cold Case
Diagnostics I don't like looking at data
from 30 years ago and trying to Retro a
situation okay okay here's why
um because 30 years ago they were not
asking questions about trauma they
weren't asking questions about
environment they weren't asking
questions about grief
so okay meaning you could do an intake
at some of these places and your husband
had just died
and they would ask you on the
questionnaire
are you having suicidal thoughts yes or
are you struggling with this yes are you
struggling with this yes bam diagnosis
okay and so there's I
I I don't she needs to go get checked
out now he's gonna sit with somebody now
if she will she won't she won't he is
actively in in therapy or Counseling of
some sort now okay all right so let's
let's move over to she truly has
borderline personality disorder
um I'm of the opinion outside of of what
I would call true psychiatric disorders
like schizophrenia those are challenging
um but there's there's entire
Specialties there borderline personality
disorder is I think it's the toughest
thing to deal with both as a clinician
both as a family member both as somebody
suffering from borderline personality
disorder here's why yeah your core
signals are off
yes fear love
on my team against me those are so
um Amplified
in a way that okay I mean you if you
grew up with it and it's true then there
were days when your mom would hold your
face and look at you in the eyes and say
every day of my life I thank God that
you're my daughter you're the greatest
daughter that has ever existed
and as a 10 year old you can hardly
breathe because your chest is so puffed
up and you're you're so excited and then
later that afternoon your mom will sit
down and take a knee and say everything
about you disgusts me my life would be
so much better if you weren't here
and you as a 10 year old are going uh
right is that is that is that track
um there were a lot of ups and downs I
think my mom did more sleeping than she
did like laying into me okay about
things so avoidance
she there it was either she was feeling
great and she was being crafty and
creative or she was sleeping or she was
down
okay
that doesn't doesn't that doesn't ring
the the borderline bells to me but we
also had an opiate addiction so
because why not right yeah lead with
that lead with that
um so I'm sorry there's so many layers
to this I wasn't sure even what to start
with okay I'm I'm messing with you I
know this is I I'm I'm trying to bring
some levity I know this is a mess
um so let's let's let's think outside
the diagnosis okay okay and that's
something with my one of my friends call
me when I'm just having a personal
conversation with my buddies that's one
of the most common things to say is like
let's think out of the diagnosis let's
just look at the world that's in front
of us okay all right you've got a mom
that is filling the blank for me she's
what uh
uh have a mom who I haven't seen in six
months she lives
to see her because she won't see you
she's avoid you you don't go over there
she's a hoarder because uh she is a
hoarder uh I think
for the holiday she opted out of the
holidays she said she wasn't feeling
well okay
uh she I didn't hear from her on my
birthday which this is the first year
that's ever happened okay
I think she's just in such a deep dark
place right now that she doesn't want
her grandkids to see her like that and
she doesn't want
um she just wants to tell us she doesn't
feel well to avoid like any intervention
we think we might need to have with her
what has kept you from going to knock on
the door and say you're my mom and I
love you and you're not okay
um
I don't know if I have a solution to
offer her when she collapses and says
I'm not okay because she's told me she's
not okay for 43 years
foreign
and I don't feel equipped to solve
whatever problem she
you know presents to me okay
um so one thing I would recommend you do
and I and again I want to honor this
powerlessness I get it she's an adult
and there's nothing harder than seeing
people that we love who are adults
struggling and they don't invite us into
that conversation or they present us
they drop bricks in our backpack that I
don't know what to do with this I don't
have the training and all the skill set
I don't have anything like that right
yeah and so um I'm just gonna tell you
if this was my mom what I would do
because I don't have the
training to sit down and do borderline
personality disorder and at 70 I can't
imagine the entrenchment um I I've I've
never even read about somebody trying to
heal from borderline at 70. okay yeah I
I just walked alongside so many of my
college students and it was hard it was
really difficult because they had to
learn that when they felt scared that
they might not their bodies are lying to
them is basically you gotta you gotta
get to where I have to
step back from my emotions and
recalibrate and it's just hard it's
really hard to do
um so
if I'm you I would reach out to her
current therapist do you know who that
person is
no I don't okay
um I would do everything I could to find
out who that person is
okay and they can't unless your your mom
has written a release to where you can
talk to that person they can tell you
that she's even a client
um okay
they can take information One Way
meaning you can write her counselor a
letter
put in writing or an email
and say my mom is expressing things in a
way that is making me think she's
suicidal or she is on a deep negative
trajectory
and I'm very worried about her and I'm
interested in partnering partnering with
you if you think there is a need and a
counselor if there is a direct threat to
self or others can breach that
confidentiality it's a nuclear option
but they can do that okay
I'll also say if she's seeing somebody
and this person is competent and they're
licensed and all that stuff
right then they should be trained to
know I'm watching a trend line here that
is making me uncomfortable and making me
nervous I've got to reach out to
um some Lifeline that's right
okay I've got to reach out to a
psychiatrist or to a team or to a social
worker or do you have family or whatever
yeah and so
um and it may be that you asked your mom
um I'm not in a position I I don't I
don't know how to help you with your
addiction on how to help you with your
mental health stuff I would love to
partner with your counselor so that you
have support everywhere
that's a good suggestion and what she
can do is sign a release and give you
permission to their counselor permission
to talk back and forth with you
okay I think she'd be willing to tell me
who her who she's talking to right now I
think that's she might be open to that
okay sometimes they will write back and
say
I am not currently seeing a client named
Kelly
yeah and sometimes that's a big
indicator right
often they'll say that indicator it's a
big indicator maybe your mom's not
seeing somebody and you she you think
she is oh yeah yeah right or that she
saw somebody three years ago and that's
quote unquote her person
and so she's going to somebody right
okay all I have to say is this
um
I'd also wouldn't would reach out to
Social Services or local services in
your area that
help the elderly
possible have conversations about
Assisted Living if I don't know what
your finances are
um we're having broader conversations
now because we're 70 and mom's still
struggling with addiction and now she's
starting to shudder the doors trying to
disappear on us
um and again I hate this because Mom can
say leave me alone
gosh leave me alone
I can't think of a more gut-wrenching
horrible like situation to be in
um so let's let's exhaust every possible
Avenue for support and care
you're not going to be the therapist
you're not going to be the person
writing scripts you're not going to be
the person actually doing the care
you're gonna you might be the The Hub of
the wheel for a while
playing traffic cop playing direct like
if you talk to this person here talk to
this person but at the end of the day
unfortunately your mom's gonna have to
make some final decisions the last
option you got is to file a petition
with the local court that to take away
her
her rights that she is incompetent too
she's unable to make decisions for
herself
she's a harm to sell for others and you
need to step in and that's going to
depend on man who is the
who's your caretaker you have to give
your brothers and sisters and have that
conversation that's a broader
conversation and that's a last option
right because you're saying this person
can't take care of themselves they can't
make adult decisions for themselves I
need to step in to be their caretaker
um and then the burden of proof is on
you to prove that this person can't do
that and that's that's a tough tough
road to hoe but
um I wrote a hoe but
just for what it's worth I'm grateful to
know people like you love their mom and
I know that's been a tough tough tough
life that you've lived with a woman
who's had a lot of struggles really been
struggling
uh let's think outside the diagnosis
right now and focus Less on Googling
things about uh you know manic
depressive bipolar disorder or Googling
things about
um
uh borderline personality just all that
stuff
and instead let's focus on resources in
our local committee for helping Mom
and bring in your brothers and sisters
in on this one I'm so sorry Jessica let
me know if I can help it any other way